if you're not a scammer uh you can just
skip this one i guess we should clarify
if you're not you don't rap if you're
not an influencer in l.a
probably can just tap the skip one on
this
because i want to talk to the scammers
okay for the scammers listen everyone
else left
okay guys
look i'm begging you
y'all have to slow it down okay
i
i'm at my wit's end here okay
i need help frankly because i haven't
slept in like three weeks i haven't seen
my wife
in like a month
you guys are running so many scams right
now it's out of control i can't i can't
talk about them all
dude i got influencers showing up on my
timeline running a scam they got a
million subs i'm like dude i can't fit
you until january let me show you guys
my schedule
6 am to 10 pm dude i'm booked through
december dude through christmas dude i
don't
i don't have time you scam i expose
that's how it's been always been but
right now there's an imbalance
because there's so many scams i don't
know what to do
you know i'm supposed to have weekends
i'm supposed to have a life logan jake
kyle steve
every rapper in existence please hey cut
me some slack here take a week off
that's all i'm saying right why are you
guys working so hard that's what i got
to ask i thought you guys were making
money with this stuff i'm begging okay
please
take a day off
for my sake and yeah i think if we can
all do that if we can all agree to that
things will go very
wait what's this
little no no no no not little uzi
there we go again
[Music]